but how do you do that right and so so
i'll throw it back to this this you know
the story i was telling right when you
have people who are in a i mean look
frederick maryland is not the biggest
city in the country it's moderately
sized just it's about an hour or so
outside of dc
no one showed up
to tell these people do as you're told
or else it was just all of a sudden like
an official announcement went out
everyone heard about the official
announcement so they all put flyers in
there in their doors and said okay
that's it we're just gonna do it now
because i heard it through the grapevine
and that's that's not even about
recruiting that's just when the state
decrees it everyone just says okay
but what if all those people actually
had careers and jobs and families they
were working on right now they wouldn't
even noticed well no i mean
this is a business right everyone's here
working at their job and all of a sudden
they're told by someone else oh they did
a mask mandate so sure you don't want to
get in trouble better do as you're told
and they all say okay but you just put
the point you don't get in trouble yep
right once you make the second piece is
no opportunities
so when i have limited opportunities and
my only opportunity is just to sell
water
i will do anything to sell water because
if i lose an opportunity i got nothing
so if i think my only chance is really
this job that i have i will do whatever
it takes to keep this job if that means
gotta yell at you i'm yelling at you if
i gotta throw you out physically i'll do
it because i want that job so i'm saying
the environment is the issue what i
don't want to do is punish the player
what i want to do is change the game
right people tend to react to their
environments
and the more we have the right
environment the less people whack badly
i feel like so that's what i want so i'm
sorry to answer your question how do you
handle a mob right remember in a mob the
person who runs the mob is the guy or
gal who yells loudest
that's who controls the mob so you've
got to be over there and you've got to
be able to talk to that leader
and get them to either acquiesce or look
weak or stop or agree with you or in
some way shape or form where the group
goes oh
you know what maybe i should be watching
netflix instead of being here let me
look i want to point i want to tell you
a story real quick that
proves your point
about whoever whoever controls the mob
the person who yells the loudest is the
person who controls the mob and it's
it's it's it's literal it's absolutely
literal so during occupy wall street
there's this very funny moment where
everybody shows up to defend the park
rumors of a police raid were coming
everyone shows up in the early hours of
the morning and there's a huge there's
thousands there's a couple thousand
people there at zuccotti park and occupy
some guy's standing up on this ledge
because the park slopes downhill so
there's there's a part where you're like
a five-foot ledge and he does the mic
check mic check and then everyone yells
and he goes uh should we uh maybe go
march and then everyone mutters and
looks around nothing happens then some
woman goes mike jack and then they all
yell mike check us i say i say we
go merch and then everyone goes wow they
all just started following her
that was just it was an amazing thing to
watch i'm like the guy asked if you
wanted to do it and no one knew when the
lady just screamed everyone just started
marching yes absolutely magical that
people just hey if you yell that i'll do
it yes absolutely the the issue is
there's a there's a book called the book
of five rings by um miyamoto musashi yes
one of my favorite books excellent book
book on sword fighting by the greatest
sword swordsman in japan real person
it's actually mistranslated it's
supposed to be the book of five scrolls
but they messed up and the ring you used
to put the scroll in so they messed up
and translating it so it's actually the
book of five scrolls and in the book he
mentioned the idea of fighting multiple
enemies
right he talks about the idea of if you
have a lot of enemies in front of you
don't be afraid
drop the leader the rest will run
that's his entire piece now i take that
not literal i take that as control the
leader i i use the lincoln analogy if i
make my enemy my friend haven't i
destroyed my enemy
so i don't have to kill the leader i
have to make the leader my friend i mean
leader my friend the mob goes away the
same thing or you're not the leader the
rest dispersed you're a slave like what
they did with the incans they took i'd
rather not
though they took i think was the spanish
took the empire house the emperor
hospital that's great they basically
kept him as like a house servant for
absolutely a month or so and they
controlled the empire it wasn't
montezuma was the incan
of the incan one yeah
and they they controlled the inca empire
after that and then they killed him
quietly yep uh but yeah that's how you
do it you take the lead right in battle
if you cut down the leader the troops
don't know what to do this is old battle
too so modern age my new battle this is
why the marine corps always has rules in
the marine corps if you ever see the
marines we have a blood stripe right
we're the only we are the only uh
only service that has a red stripe in
our dress uniform that blood stripe
comes from the battle of chipotle is
that right i think that's right um
is that right i'm not one of the battles
in the mexican war i think that was the
right one where the officers were killed
and the non-commissioned officers took
over
and still captured the city anyway
and from that only e-4s and above get
that red blood stripe the marine corps
teaches you that
when the captain shot the hill still
must be taken
which is so when leaders get killed
marines still step up and do the job
this is what leadership is about good
leadership is about creating more
leaders
which is why often cults of personality
fail because once that person is gone
there's no more leaders there it's all
gone if you create a movement a real
movement you create more leaders around
you so one guy drops the rest pop up and
the hill is still taking right it's not
that we don't need a leader it's that we
need lots of them yes i always say the
liberty movement does not need a savior
it needs hundreds of heroes
it is hundreds of heroes the battle of
chapel tepec in 1847 chipotle okay
that's where that's cool
i still remember my uh my marine corps
history i was an e4 i've been a marine
it was an e4 that picked up the no it
was a bunch of non-commissioned officers
e4 and above who basically picked up the
issue and kept going if you ever watch i
had my watch my uh my daughter and i
watched the movie um full metal jacket
if you ever watch the part where they're
ready to attack the city of way
and as they're moving into way city
there's a bunch of explosions the
captain drops the second the captain
drops the snapshot gets up let's move
and the staff sergeant takes him and
he's still moving it to the city anyway
band of brothers too man when they drop
behind enemy lines the the captain goes
down and the lieutenant's forced to take
over all the league have that all of the
units have but mobs don't mobs are not
elite
so mobs don't have that trained elite
units have that esprit de corps they
have that way of thinking mobs don't it
was napoleon who said if you want to get
rid of a mob give them a whiff of
grapeshot right fire around in a model
disperse
yeah my favorite movie to quote of
course the patriot with mel gibson
there's that great scene where he's
talking with i think it's cornwallis and
he says stop killing my officers could
you imagine what war would be like
people running about and and then he has
you know that's the point but i love he
responds he was like so long as your
officers will are killing women and
children we will i will order my men to
fire on site which is awesome i love
that movie mel gibson was amazing in it
but that's the point that was you know
don't kill the officers just kill the
the lowly people and then let the
officers live because we don't want
disorganized warfare it's it's it's an
insane thing to think that there was a
time where people were like we're going
to war and i want you dead but we'll be
gentlemanly about it because you would
you would capture the enemy duke and
then you'd sell them back for 10 times
the money you would make with a peace
deal or with a beheading and then their
son becomes the duke and hates you
there's no point so you're saying our
approach to anti-was all wrong we should
be capturing their leaders
they wouldn't be that valuable i think
that's what the law system has been
doing they've been incarcerating them
and bailing them out basically isn't
that a similar thing they're paying
themselves yeah
actually
yeah they arrest them and then the
antifa raises money through crowdfunding
to pay to get him out of jail keeping
this industry rolling could you imagine
if that's the real reason there's not
enough there's there's not as many
prosecutions with anti-fun they get
released a lot because there's an
industry around it i paid lawyers
politicians getting funding donations
crowdfunding websites they're all like
look look if we convict them
then we stop getting the money from this
economy of activism and we and we have
to pay to incarcerate them on top
that's right we lose money i wish that
was unbelievable but it's not i wish
that was unbelievable but it's totally
but hey but but but i mean what would
you do i mean that's a free market right
no no government's by default not a free
market yeah by default once it's
government it's by default not a free
market right so no not at all how do you
bounce that out libertarian style with
with like the authority of governments
take having control of the authority of
government and being libertarian about
it that is one of the broadest questions
i've ever had to be a little more
specific how do you feel about like
public roads being owned by the
government yeah as a general rule that's
that's not a real thing in america like
americans don't want to hear that so my
idea has always been instead you raise
money for infrastructure by leasing out
naming rights from that infrastructure
so an example in new york city is a
great example meaning so for example we
have dozens of bridges in new york city
they get mentioned hundreds of times
every day um on you know the the reports
the traffic reports um we see them on
google maps they're in uh tv shows all
the time imagine instead of it being the
george washington bridge it was the
netflix bridge or the pepsi bridge the
bloodlight bridge
a year how do i know that because i
brought this up in 2018 and there were
bankers talking to me about what how
long is the lease what are we talking
about how long will it go because you
have to have it for at least 12 years at
least 10 year lease because culture has
to also change right so just because i
want to name it the pepsi bridges i mean
i still don't call the george washington
bridge so culture has to change to get
the pepsi piece on there plus they also
control maintenance but we still own the
asset we own the asset a leasing right
leasing naming rights to them you front
load the contract so if they screw up on
the maintenance we remove the contract
we get our money up front new contract
so now what happens you raise money you
end the tolls tolls in new york 15 to 18
bucks for one bridge one way yep you get
rid of those tolls now the regular
working poor and the middle class can
drive across the bridge truckers
independent truckers aren't getting
hammered because they pay per axle so
that now goes away and you don't have to
pay for the maintenance of the bridge
you take the cash you pay for the mta
this is brilliant
maybe we should uh auction the name of
free damastan so it'll be like netflix
oh my gosh you'd make a podcast at least
18 million bucks for the first year next
week netflixia netflix
i don't know if any of these
corporations would want to be uh uh
associated with our freedom
but so we're building the new uh
facility it's like 50 acres in the
middle of west virginia nice so uh yeah
why don't we just do that we just like
hey if you want you want to name it you
got to pay it's only it's only good for
we'll do a five year lease but that's
what government should be doing but it
won't here's the reason why government
is backward
in other words government says we're
doing something so government should pay
some crony some friend that i have to do
the work with taxpayer money
should be the opposite i'm giving you
government land or government you should
pay me
why am i why because well if you pay me
i can't reward my friends with jobs and
remember government is always two things
a monopoly and a jobs program it's
always those two things if you take away
the jobs program then take away the
monopoly government has very little
power
so they want to make sure that they're
always spending money to create jobs so
you become loyal to the government yep
right so that's why they always create
an office of this and office of that and
they put 40 million dollars towards the
10 million dollars towards it because
now my buddy and his son and daughter
all get jobs now
and once you get your population
dependent on government-controlled
health care yeah you never got to worry
about losing power ever again correct do
you think in like the age of uh
fifth generational warfare meme warfare
and stuff that naming roads and bridges
corporate names is dangerous why just
because it brainwashes people to think
the corporations are in control they
already think it and and then the other
thing is they already think it number
one and in many cases they are i mean
amazon is in heavy control already but
no matter what the person is actually in
control is the person who can arrest you
that's the person who's actually in
control right whoever can arrest you is
actually in control so that's number one
but the second piece is there won't just
be one bridge
they can get two bridges it's fine but
there'll be a bunch of bricks but but
this is actually a really good idea
because check out this right when you're
when you're leaving new york you got a
couple different options for your bridge
yes right depending on where you're
going so uh when you're when you're
going north out of the w washington
bridge george washington bridge what's
what's another option outside of the
george washington bridge in the same
direction you can go to tappan zee
bridge what's actually called the mario
cuomo bridge oh i still call it because
they we need to remember something we
are an empire so we always have to name
our monuments over about our royalty i
would love to rename fdmr now hold on
yes so you've got you've got the cuomo
bridge and the washington bridge right
yeah now imagine because this is an
amazing idea imagine new york leases
them out and then coke buys one yep and
pepsi buys the other that'd be awesome
analytics but hold on then one day
you're driving and you hit a pothole on
the coke bridge and you post on twitter
these potholes in the coke bridge or
trash i'm taking pepsi coke's gonna be
like we gotta fix this bridge absolutely
so much to fix the potholes and they'll
fix it fast they will yeah and that's a
great incentive yeah and cheaper you
could rename it the fdr what is it a
freeway the fdr the ftr drive that would
be nice to rename absolutely
it's kind of scary to think though that
you're going to be like you're going to
make a right onto netflix once you get
to the pepsi bridge yes you need to exit
onto the kfc highway yes but the other
options
the other option is horrible
infrastructure being paid for poor
people right the advantage of this right
now is the left will always say i want
corporations to pay more
me too
let's just do it voluntarily
well they're going to voluntarily pay
for your infrastructure you want i want
you know netflix to pay for the mta i'll
get them to do it
they'll happily do it companies like
google and such have a 10 billion dollar
marketing budget
that's just the marketing budget per
year 100 million dollars easy day they
don't care do you think it would be okay
to sell the name of new york city no go
and just call it google no no no no no
no no google no terrible idea but what's
the difference infrastructure is
infrastructure once you do the city
that's monopoly
it's just a name but it's the city it's
one city you've just made into the
monopoly we have enough monopolies i
want to sell things where there's lots
of
right but lots of and they can compete
against each other
lots of they might want to buy two or
three of them good put tons not all of
them what if what if google buys every
available infrastructure outbids
everybody and so it's like once you exit
at google one you turn left on google
three google four is when you it's a
valid point and if that becomes a
problem let's cross that bridge nice uh
right yes if if i hope that becomes a
problem i hope one company wants to
spend three billion dollars on and pay
for new york's city's infrastructure let
that be a problem it's a problem i mean
i mean truth be told uh like when it
came to setting up free damastan we just
called that i think luke came up with
the name it's like you know like
afghanistan or whatever stan meaning
city and so he was like call it free
damastan or something freedom is stan
and i said free damastan uh we could
raise money to expand our operation by
offering someone up the the the chance
to to buy the naming rights for certain
amount of time and then whenever we're
talking about it we would call it like
you know joe's plumbing yes you know
headquarters or whatever 100 why not
look i was talking about the mta right
the mta is an old system right the
disadvantage of new york city is that
its system's very old the subway is over
100 years old it takes forever to fix
anything to repair anything so i want a
brand new system it's too expensive and
it's a garbage system how do you fix it
okay at night for those who don't know
an mta at night literally
every other train it's done over the
train so make every train a freight
train allow freight to come into the
city well the first response i get is
well you can't have freight coming to
the city the tracks aren't ready for
that i guess that means that fedex and
home depot and amazon have to build all
new tracks won't they
and what we'll do is every hub they
create they name their own hubs so it's
the home depot hub it's the so-and-so
hub it's not gonna be the moynihan
station again named after our elites
it'll be the home depot station that'll
be the so-and-so station they'll get all
that right they'll rebuild the entire
system we'll get more freight going to
the city less trucks on city roads at
night
they're happy we're happy and we get a
brand new system and we can lower the
cost to about a buck a ride have you
considered running for some kind of
political audience i have and here's the
worst part that plan has been on my
website for four years wow no one's
taken it i mean we talked about great
ideas one of the one of the nightmares
of new york is is shipping yep
it's so diff in new york city
particularly yes getting getting goods
into a city so dense is insane the roads
are are shot correct parking is
ridiculous they've banned like you can't
non-commercial vehicles can't even park
in in manhattan because it's just too
congested correct
i like your plan this happens now now
literally if you want to be eco-friendly
the city isn't a place where you have
enough hubs you could literally have
walkers
people who are walking goods people who
are backpacking you could use bikes
whatever you want an uber type of thing
you could make uber whatever is the
right thing the point is as a governor i
don't have to make that decision i
change the environment
and then i got better players larry
larry solving problems for for regular
working people it doesn't work for the
elites because the problems keep them in
power but as long as i give them
something which if you notice i'm always
giving the elite something and it will
create new problems for them to worry
correct
i give the elisa because if you try to
just fight the elite straight up one on
one you lose
so don't charge a machine gun nest
correct so i bring them aboard i bring
them aboard and helping me out right
they they here's what i'm sure of amazon
wants to advertise so does google and
everyone else and they don't know how
they're throwing this stuff all over the
place they're figuring out how this
thing works i'm giving you away and i'll
talk about it on top of it as a governor
i'll talk about it dude a fifth avenue
was amazon
ave and then you had like
bath and beyond i don't want to change
the at the streets
the streets are in manhattan are all
numbers it helps you and it's not going
to get to navigate so i don't want to
change streets right that's going to run
up all my policies are always set up to
help the working poor in the middle
class
but this is this isn't and that will
hurt the working poor middle class so
i'm not okay with that so if if we're
talking about
uh bringing freight into the city on the
tracks and an existing massive what you
said rebuild be rebuilt by trucks that's
going to save these these companies
insane amounts of money yes so they're
they have a massive prop and profit
incentive for investing in this if they
get access to it yes and it's just their
marketing budget anyway they're not
paying any extra money no i mean like uh
so i'm not causing the plenty of extra
money out of their budget but they're
putting more money into into
infrastructure but but i'm not talking
about the naming rights i'm talking
about necessarily i'm also i'm also
talking about if you allow the trains to
come in instead of pubs right they're
going to say it's going to cost us x per
year if we invest 100 million dollars
it'll drop it'll be x minus y right
we're going to save money over 10 years
we're going to make more put more money
in our pockets 100 they'll save money
after the first year that's right yeah
so a little bit faster why thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you